ومعنا من مطار شارل دوغون موفدتنا انمار
حجازي اهلا بك انمار كيف تجري عمليه
الاجلاء وهل وصل المزيد من الرعايه
الاوروبيين
نحن في انتظار وصول الطائره الثالثه
من ياما الى باريس الى مطار شاردنغول حصل
هناك بعض التاخير في الاقلاع ستصل الطائره
عند الساعه السادسه هناك طائره اخرى ايضا
ستقلع حاليا من النيابه ستصل خلال الليل
في النيجر 1200 فرنسي يقيم هناك
حسب الدوائر القنصليه 600 عبروا عن رغبتهم
بالخروج من هناك
الطائرتان السابقتان تمكنت من اخراج
513 شخصا 350 فرنسي
وستقل الطائرات القادمه ما يقارب 250 شخصا
السفاره الفرنسيه تحدثت بشكل شخصي مع
المقيمين في النيجر وطلبت منهم حمل
اخس ما يمكن وت
خوفا من تدهور الاوضاع في النيجر بسبب
الانقلاب على الرئيس المنتخب محمد دازون
مفردتنا الى مطار
حجازي شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه التفاصيل